avec la bataille du donbass les
américains passent à l'artillerie lourde
pour aider les ukrainiens
[Musique]
il envoie des systèmes antiaériens des
missiles antinavires
des drones camicas which blais
et on ne lésine pas sur les coûts
l'enveloppé de 3 4 milliards de dollars
ici dans cet entrepôt aveu jinja beach
on n'envoie pas des armes et du matériel
de protection
on y assemble des gilets pare-balles
tous les jours
pour les ukrainiens qui se bat
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on fait 1200 gillet dit il
ses 2400 places en tout
ce sont des plaques niveau qu'a dit il
ce qui est le plus ok liban contre des
balles pour les soldats qui sont sur la
ligne de front
des casques et du matériel médical sont
aussi envoyés
tout est emballé et acheminés en pologne
dans ce boeing 777 tous les sièges sont
remplies 24 heures plus tard le matériel
arrive en ukraine will go africa une
opération qui a lieu tous les jours nous
dit-on les besoins en ukraine sont
criants d'agbar chaque jour compte gmail
le fondateur de spirit of america une
organisation à but non lucratif en
collaboration avec le gouvernement
américain
notre objectif est de garder les
ukrainiens vivant dit il une question de
principe pour gmail dont
ne soyons pas juste d observateur
impuissant dit il mais agissons pour
faire cesser cette souffrance
une souffrance qui n'est pas prête de
cesser selon joe biden qui prévoit une
longue guerre
je vais à peu dire votre travail
exceptionnel dit il aux gradés
militaires américains d'armé et
d'équiper les braves d'ukrainiens qui
défendent leur pays
une guerre par procuration des états
unis contre la russie diront certains et
toujours pas question d'envoyer des
soldats américains en sol ukrainien
et la voie diplomatique pour une
résolution du conflit et de moins en
moins évoquée c'est pour les
ukrainiennes d'être les leaders de la
diplomatie avec la russie c'est la
souveraineté de l'ukraine qui était
violet mais on a une étroite
collaboration avec l'ukraine on est là
pour l'ukraine le canada réitère son
soutien militaire et économique l
ukraine en attendant la guerre continue
ce plutôt america elle espère faire sa
part une guerre qui perdurent ou un
cessez le feu semble pour le moment
illusoire ici assez bonne figure qui
sera du canada rue jean y habitent